Sometimes - like in the case of birds and insects -
migration is built into the very DNA -
they migrate because their bodies tell them to.
But for ungulates, such as deer, sheep, and moose,
it’s long been hypothesized that seasonal migration
is a learned behavior, passed down
from one generation to the next.
The question is do they innately know
to go where the best, greenest, healthiest grazing
is at different times of the year—
or do they need to learn from others in the herd?
Researchers have now put this to the test
by tracking the movements of bighorn sheep
and moose in the American West.
They used GPS data of hoofstock
from both historic populations -- centuries old
in some cases -- and populations that had
been moved over the past few decades
due to overhunting and disease.
The researchers tracked the way these different
types of herds migrated over 2-4 years
and compared how their movements matched up
with the quality of the available food in the area.
Ideally, when ungulates migrate,
they synchronize their movements to forage for
vegetation when it’s most nutritious
and easiest to digest -
a process called “green-wave surfing”.
In the American West,
that means as the weather warms,
they follow the best fodder from lower elevations
to higher ones—
following the best greens up the mountains.
The research team used NASA’s MODIS satellite
to take snapshots of the greenery over time
while an onboard spectrometer
analyzed the forage quality.
Researchers then overlaid the data
from the animals movements gleaned from GPS collars
with these maps of forage quality
They defined an animal’s surfing ability
as the difference between day forage quality peaked
and the day the animal foraged at the location.
This map follows three historic herds of bighorn sheep
in Whiskey Basin, Wyoming
as the vegetation begins to mature.
Having lived there for centuries, they easily
follow the vegetation as it blooms up the mountain.
This map, however,
follows three relocated herds of sheep
85 miles to the north in Devils Canyon, Wyoming.
Since they’ve only lived there for a short time,
they haven’t yet learned to green-wave surf,
so they stay put.
The results showed that historic populations
were much better at riding the green wave
than populations that had recently been relocated—
suggesting that green-wave surfing migration
is learned or culturally transmitted.
It’s likely this ability takes decades to develop,
as each generation becomes familiar with the area
and passes down this knowledge to their offspring.
However, once a species is relocated
or driven locally extinct due to disease or overhunting,
that knowledge is lost forever
and could take decades to be restored.
Though this study is only based on a few herds,
the researchers believe that this emphasizes
the importance of not only establishing
new migration corridors for relocated species,
but also preserving ones that have already existed for,
in some cases, centuries.